we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's my
question for you today i asked this
question with peace and love is this a
joke or a troll is this for real and if
this is for real are we dealing with
some kind of mental disturbance or
mental illness take a listen David I
have bad news for you
Donald Trump huh as a president
disappointment of chapter six of
Revelation please please understand
David the Pharisees in Jesus's time
bribed the Romans there at the tomb to
say that the disciples stole the body of
Christ and that light has been
perpetuated throughout the jewish
generation for years okay like we're in
revelation chapter 6 and revelation 13
used the writer on the pale horse the
pale horse as the voters all pale
skinned people I'd feel Herod and his
death and Hades is my pets
okay okay he's going to kill a fourth of
mankind with sword hunger beasts and
death try as we might okay to fight him
he will inevitably win the next election
because it's going to take another four
years to kill one point nine billion
people you need to put some supplies on
the shelf okay so it goes on for a
little while longer
it doesn't sound fake to me it doesn't
sound fake to me and that's really
worrying that's really worrying because
that does not sound like stability and
unfortunately there are many enclaves of
the United States where that type of
thing is is considered okay as long as
it's couched to remember under the right
religion and you know so on and so forth
what do you think of that that that's
actually really scary stuff to me on a
number of different levels if it's just
a joke okay but
you know good I I love it but if I don't
think it is and it's concerning to me
for sure I want to hear from you about
it Canada has had its deadliest mass
shooting in history in the midst of the
corona virus pandemic we are starting to
hear universities talk about no
in-person classes until 2021 we will
discuss at that on the bonus show today
and we will also talk about the effect
of house cats on local wildlife a major
major break I would say in producer
Pat's defense of kitty cats so much of
that and more on today's bonus show
don't miss it become a member at join
pakman.com or make a pledge on patreon
at patreon.com slash david pakman show